I want to tell you a little story about
authoritarianism lack of common sense
lack of everything decent and logical
protesters caused by a talk by Milo you
nopales at UC Berkeley
showed up and started going absolutely
bonkers and it led to the talk at UC
Berkeley being canceled altogether now
I've not been talking about Milo yu-na
pelisses speeches since I think there's
nothing in newsworthy about them he
shows up he's deliberately provocative
merely to be shocking and offensive he
says things like feminism is cancer
gives irrational critiques of Islam that
go way above and beyond the critiques I
do here for which I'm also sometimes
labeled in islamaphobe but that that's a
label I completely reject but this
particular speech scheduled for last
night brought out protesters with smoke
bombs protesters who started fires
protesters who smashed windows around
1500 people showed up to peacefully
protest Milo in Opelousas speech but
then a smaller group of protesters
started a wave of absolute and total
vandalism all deplorable actions which I
opposed police decided not the
University but again police decided that
they couldn't Garrett guarantee Milo
yu-na police's safety so officers
canceled the event and escorted Milo off
campus to keep him safe no immediate
reports of arrests or serious injuries
again this was for Milo's safety how did
President Donald Trump respond number
one it's insane that Trump would even
respond to this at all of course that's
because as we know Trump rather than
reading briefings or reports is watching
TV Fox News started covering this and
very quickly Trump was tweeting about it
Trump sent out the following tweet where
he threatened to withdraw federal funds
from UC Berkeley quote if UC Berkeley
does not allow free speech and practices
violence on innocent people with a
different point of view no federal funds
keep this up for a second pad think
about how clueless our president is I
mean really folks think about how insane
he exposes he is if UC Berkeley does not
allow free speech first of all this was
a security decision
made by police on the campus it's not at
all an issue of free speech it was
canceled because Milo was unsafe at the
determination of law enforcement but
again what does it have to do with free
speech no one has a right to speak at a
university now I happen to agree with
the idea that if you support the concept
of free speech you support it for
everybody sort of directly inciting
violence on individuals and we have to
support it for someone like Milo you
Napoles as well however this is not an
issue where anyone gets is is given the
right to speak anywhere they want I'd
love to give a speech at Harvard
University they haven't invited me are
they limiting my free speech by not
having invited me we have a very
specific situation here where the
Republican Club wanted Milo to speak and
they booked him and for security reasons
police decided it wasn't safe for him
what on earth is Trump talking about and
the whole reason this is becoming a big
news story is because Donald Trump
decided to talk about this on Twitter
yeah whole reason why is because he
keeps threatening to take away federal
funds yet from universities or sanctuary
jurisdictions and then even in Chicago
he threatened to enforce martial law
yeah it's absolutely insane and that's
the the real part I want to get to the
free speech thing it's like yet Trump
understands free speech know better than
your average internet basement dweller
but think about what Trump is
threatening to do take away federal tax
payer money from a university because
police determined that Steve bannon's
buddy from Breitbart Milo you nopales
was not going to be able to safely speak
it's not even clear this would be legal
but that gets me to something really
important remember everything is legal
until the republican-controlled House
and Senate actually does something about
it that applies to Donald Trump
violating the Constitution's emoluments
clause that applies to Donald Trump
threatening to take away federal funds
from a school based on a decision made
by police about the safety of a speaker
you've got here a situation where Milo
has a right to speak if we believe in
free speech we believe in it for him as
well
that doesn't mean
that police saying it's not safe for you
is a restriction on free speech and
certainly you know this is Trump's
America this is an America where the
president sends out tweets based on
what's on Fox News rather than actually
being a sort of rational temper mentally
fit person Trump's consciousness is
dictated by television which as we heard
last week he's watching constantly to
the point of concerning his White House
staffers this is America under Donald
Trump and you know I'd like to think
this is going to end at some point but I
think we've got to get used to this
nonsense because it is happening and
it's going to continue to happen Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s